humans are corrupt every single
institution on the face of the planet
that is run by humans which is currently
all of them at some degree is corrupt
all of them whether it's doctors
financial judicial law and order the
monetary system it's all completely and
artly corrupt and to sit here and
believe that any of them are just and
fair i think we've just learned in the
last few years that we can see that even
simple things like keeping people alive
even medicine is completely corrupt from
head to toe all of it is so you have to
understand that and then you have to
look at the chess board and go okay if
it's all completely not really corrupt
and i understand that there are certain
people who get to play the game on cheap
mode
do i want to be able to play the game on
cheat mode if i'm going to try and be
the best version of myself well yes i
could possibly do that in nigeria i
could play on cheat mode i could
possibly play on sheet mode in croatia i
could possibly play on cheat mode here
here i have to stick to the rules if i
have to obey the rules of chess against
a person who can move their pieces
however they want i'm going to be
perpetually crushed for attorney